and I know it's easy to sit here
obviously and blame the Democrats
because they are in charge of the House
of Representatives but we also cannot
discount the role that Republicans are
playing in all of this after all
Republicans at least on the surface
don't want any kind of accountability
for Donald Trump whatsoever
let the man be just let him do what he's
gonna do right well actually there are
some Republicans who were starting to
get annoyed by the fact that the
president seems to think he and his
cabinet and his officials are all above
the law very rare very few but there are
some and I'm not just talking about a
Republican representative Justin Amash
there's others according to a new report
by political here you have
representative Ken buck you have
representative Tom Cole you have
representative Mike Simpson and of
course representative Amash those are
for Republicans who even though they may
not be happy with the Democrats and
their investigations into Donald Trump
they have also expressed their concern
over the fact that the president refuses
to comply with any of these
investigations along with the other
people from his office so again Ken buck
from Colorado Tom Cole from Oklahoma
Mike Simpson from Idaho and Justin Amash
from Michigan are all Republican members
of the House of Representatives who are
starting to get fed up with the
president and this is according to a
report in Politico here's what this
means because believe it or not there is
some good that comes out of this story
it shows us that there are cracks in the
facade that people within the Republican
Party who actually hold positions of
power meaning US representative they're
starting to wonder why the president is
behaving this way they're starting to
say publicly that this isn't okay and
whether or not he agrees with the
investigations whether or not I agree
with the investigations he has to do
this he is not above the law
unfortunately one of their big fears
that they have is not just about Trump
it's about setting the precedent
for future presidents to ignore any and
all investigations or document requests
or subpoenas coming from the House of
Representatives see so now the truth
kind of starts to unravel a little bit
it's not just that oh we want Trump to
comply and behave it's Nona to know
we're looking into the future and
eventually we know we're going to have
another Democratic president and we may
want to investigate them and we want
them to cooperate but if Trump doesn't
and the courts rule he doesn't have to
then by golly we're never going to be
hold to be able to hold another Democrat
accountable ever again so the truth
comes out a little bit right these
Republicans aren't necessarily worried
that Donald Trump is ruining the
reputation of the presidency or that
he's completely disregarding the law and
acting like he is above it no they're
worried that their future attempts to go
after Democrats are gonna fail based on
what Donald Trump is doing today but I
guess you got to take an ally wherever
you can get them right because if these
Republicans are saying that Donald Trump
needs to comply we kinda have to say
okay we agree with you we don't agree
with your long game here but we need
allies or do we that's another question
we have to answer do we need these
Republican allies with ulterior motives
because we don't actually when you look
at the numbers the Democrats don't need
any Republicans to join with them in the
House of Representatives for impeachment
we already have the numbers we can make
it happen the place we need allies is in
the Senate and that ain't ever gonna
happen I ain't even Mitt Romney who's
wagging his finger at Donald Trump
telling him oh you're doing horrible
things he still admits freely that I
don't think impeachments the way to go
we're not gonna do that so once again we
have another Jeff Flake in the Senate
this time it just happens to be Mitt
Romney but Mitt I got to put it to you
this way bud what if it's a big if what
if you were to join in with Democrats
and maybe get a couple of your other
Republicans over to there
so you could vote to convict and remove
from office in the Senate and then
suddenly oh there might be room for a
Republican challenger to Mike Pence in
the 2020 primaries
oh that seems like the perfect
opportunity for a guy like Mitt Romney
to jump into the presidential race right
so just just think about it mitt right
you wanted to be President I'm sure you
still want to be President if you didn't
you wouldn't have run for Senate you
still have ambitions you still have
goals but there is one man standing in
your way and that man happens to be
Donald Trump but you if you get enough
allies in the Senate you could
absolutely do something about that Mike
Pence is a pushover
he is not popular or charismatic enough
to win a primary so mitt just a little
bit of friendly advice there for the
record I do not want you to be President
of the United States I think he would be
just as bad as Donald Trump you just
wouldn't be as abrasive on the outside
but I'm just saying I know you're
ambitious so follow your ambition and do
the right thing in this one instance
because you could but as for these other
folks in the House of Representatives
who are saying Oh Donald Trump is
frustrating because he's not obeying the
law keep in mind that while they may be
saying that now it's not because they're
mad at Trump it's because they're mad
they may not be able to hold future
Democrats accountable we need to take
another quick break we'll be right back
with more on the David Pakman show